[Musique]
c'est l'heure du journal de l'afrique
ravi de vous retrouver soyez les
bienvenus à la une ce soir le togo
médiateur dans la crise au mali la
proposition faite par bamako a été
acceptée par le président faure
gnassingbé il facilitera donc le
dialogue entre le gouvernement malien de
transition et la cedeao mais aussi avec
les autres instances internationales
nous irons en république du congo la
prise en charge des patients atteints de
troubles mentaux fait gravement défaut
les familles se retrouvent démunis face
à la maladie de leur proche le personnel
de santé dénoncent le manque de moyens
en psychiatrie
et si la nouvelle star du psg venait du
rwanda 184 jeune rwandaise sont
entraînés dans l'académie de football
ouverte par le club parisien il y a
quelques mois et cela grâce à un accord
noué entre le psg et le gouvernement
rwandais
reportage à suivre dans ce journal
après plusieurs médiations qui ont
jusque là échoué le togo a accepté de
reprendre le flambeau à la demande du
mali c'est l'eau mais ne cache pas sa
proximité avec le gouvernement de
transition à bamako une délégation
malienne a d'ailleurs été reçus mercredi
dans la capitale togolaise la démarche
malienne auprès des autorités togolaises
intervient après les sévères sanctions
de la cedeao faure gnassingbé aura donc
la lourde tâche d'aider à une sortie de
crise les précisions de notre
correspondante emmanuel sodji
des sanctions qui frappent le pays
depuis près de quatre mois en raison
d'un second coup d'état militaire dirigé
par le colonel assimilés aux états il ya
maintenant un an alors ces sanctions
sont financières avec la suspension du
mali des activités de la banque centrale
des états de l'afrique de l'ouest elles
sont aussi commercial avec la fermeture
des frontières aériennes et terrestres
et depuis on assiste un va et vient
continu du ministère du ministre des
affaires étrangères du togo entre lomé
et bamako par le but affiché c'est de
rapprocher les positions entre la cedeao
et le mali le point d'achoppement étant
la durée la transition alors ce n'est
pas la première fois qu'une délégation
de bamako se retrouve à lomé mais cette
fois ci la démarche est formel les
maliens espère ainsi avec l'aide de lomé
sortir de la crise avec la cedeao
d'après robert dussey le ministre
togolais des affaires étrangères faure
gnassingbé a accepté d'aider le mali
selon certains le togo semble ainsi
vouloir jouer un rôle de médiateur dans
les crises qui secoue le continent
d'ailleurs le togo s'est aussi impliqué
au tchad après l'arrivée au pouvoir de
mama titrisent débit qui avait suscité
beaucoup de remous implication aussi en
guinée-bissau au moment de la crise
politique et puis cet activisme du
président togolais dans les crises du
mali et du tchad est régulièrement
dénoncée par l'opposition togolaise
selon elle l'exécutif recherche des
solutions pour d'autres pays alors que
le togo est lui-même est dans une crise
politique permanente
à la une également alpha condé interdit
de sortie de guinée une mesure qui
intervient au lendemain de l'annoncé de
poursuites judiciaires contre l'ex
président la justice a également ordonné
la saisie de ses biens jusqu'à la
clôture de l'anc est en cours cette
décision concerne aussi et 26 autres
dirigeants poursuivis pour crime la
presse guinéenne s'est largement fait
l'écho de l'annnonce du procureur
général une décision saluée par les
victimes du régime déchu la réaction à
conakry avec notre correspondant maliki
et diakité
le sujet est largement commentée à
conakry et il fait la une des médias à
les familles des victimes à présumer les
organisations de défense des droits de
l'homme tout ce registre de l'ouverture
de cette information judiciaire contre
le président dessus alpha condé et vingt
six anciens hauts dirigeants pour des
faits présumés d'assassinats de tortue
et enlèvement ces poursuites ont été
engagées suite aux manifestations contre
le troisième mandat d'alpha condé
violemment réprimées par le pouvoir
d'alors selon m thierno souleymane baldé
l'avocat des victimes il faut encore une
volonté politique pour la tenue d'un
procès
même si c'est vrai nous sommes contents
par rapport à la décision était prise
par le professionnel mais nous sommes
aussi réalistes par rapport aux
difficultés qui pourraient
resurgir avant qu'il y ait un procès il
faut une volonté politique
affichée
sans ambages nous nous voulons connaître
la vérité nous voulons savoir qui a été
impliqué qui a fait quoi le rpg
rassemblement du peuple de guinée
d'alpha condé n'a pas souhaité réagir
alpha condé lui est à conakry à la
résidence de son épouse mais d'autres
poursuites pourraient suivre selon
certaines informations elle concernerait
cette fois ci les opposants au régime
déchu et certains acteurs de la société
civile qui étaient les organisateurs de
ces différentes manifestations dans le
pays des rassemblements alors interdite
pas une goutte de pluie depuis des mois
du sud de l'ethiopie au nord du kenya en
passant par la somalie la corne de
l'afrique fait face à une importante
sécheresse la plus grave depuis 1981
depuis des mois donc des régions
entières sont privés d'eau 20 millions
de personnes sont concernées la famine
touche désormais les populations
laura roudaut
en ethiopie pas une goutte de pluie
depuis 18 mois la plupart de ces
éleveurs nomades ont perdu le quatre
cinquièmes de leur troupeau que dieu
nous aide
il donne de la pluie
j'ai vu des chameaux manger doko chameau
j'avais jamais vu ça je ne pense pas que
notre mode de vie son vivant beaucoup
vivent ici de l'élevage et de
l'agriculture
mais leurs bêtes quand elles survivent
sont six mais qu'elles sont invendables
les enfants sont les premières victimes
de la sécheresse dénutri les maires ne
produisent pas suffisamment de lait
maternel la famine menace 1,7 million
d'enfants dans la corne de l'afrique où
les prix des denrées alimentaires ont
flambé depuis le début du conflit en
ukraine épuisé souvent affamées ces
somaliens contraints de quitter leur
région vivent dans un camp de réfugiés
le nord du kenya aussi est menacée cinq
cent mille personnes seraient même en
insécurité alimentaire les agents de
l'onu sur place déplore le manque de
fonds fournis aux pays de la corne de
l'afrique
après trois saisons sont pluie on estime
que la région est la plus sèche depuis
40 ans
nous attendons maintenant que la saison
des pluies arrive
elle est tardive et nous sommes très
inquiet des conséquences qu'elle aura si
elle est inférieure à la moyenne les
experts l'annoncent déjà avec le
dérèglement climatique
ces épisodes de sécheresses vont devenir
de plus en plus fréquents en somalie la
date de la présidentielle enfin fixée
elle se tiendra le dimanche 15 mai
l'élection attendue depuis plus d'un an
été à plusieurs reprises reportée en
raison de conflits au sein de l'exécutif
mais aussi entre le gouvernement central
et certains états fédéraux le mandat du
président sortant mohamed abdullahi
mohamed vi fam à jo et arrive à aider à
échéance en février
les directions la république du congo
c'est un drame qui a relancé le débat
sur la prise en charge des personnes
atteintes de troubles mentaux fin mars
un bébé ou un bébé mouret après avoir
été arraché des bras de sa mère et jeté
au sol par une femme cette dernière
atteinte d'une maladie psychiatrique
n'avait jamais bénéficié de la moindre
prise en charge comme elle des centaines
de malades à travers le pays n'ont pas
accès aux soins et les structures
d'accueil sont quasi inexistantes voyez
ce reportage de rosie piotte
viviane kolélas est à la recherche de
son neveu dans les rues de pointe noire
c'est devenu presque une habitude pour
la quinquagénaire le jeune homme atteint
de troubles mentaux depuis une dizaine
d'années fugue régulièrement de chez lui
nous avons été surpris par ces maux de
tête récurrents et sur conseils de
quelqu'un nous nous sommes rendus à
l'hôpital avant d'aller dans les églises
après les examens effectués et le
traitement prescrit par le médecin on a
constaté une accalmie et la rechute a eu
lieu un mois plus tard la même bande
malgré ce diagnostic le neveu de viviane
ne bénéficie d'aucun suivi médical comme
des milliers de malades à travers le
pays il est livré à lui même et dépend
de sa famille pour survivre dauphin
mater mollo est le seul psychiatre de
pointe-noire la deuxième ville du pays
où il n'existe plus aucune unité
d'hospitalisation en soins
psychiatriques depuis les années 80 qui
les revend sur les paroles avec un gros
pincement au coeur parce que même devant
un jury
comment le moment c'est pourquoi
commandement la dht comment les malades
et agressé verbalement et physiquement
mais je demande aux parents de rentrer à
la maison faute de pavillon
d'hospitalisation un programme national
de santé mentale existe pourtant
république du congo depuis 2010 9 laissé
animateurs n'ont été nommé que fin 2020
le décès d'un bébé à brazzaville famars
arraché à sa mère et j'étais au sol par
une malade qu'il ait bénéficié d'aucun
suivi pourrait donner un coup
d'accélérateur à sa mise en place cette
situation
nous a énormément interpellé en tant que
programme national de santé mentale et
nous souhaitons que cela ne se
reproduise plus et pour cela il nous
faut vraiment avoir un soutien de nos
différentes armées afin que ce problème
des patients soit résolu le programme
national estime à plus de 1500 le nombre
de malades ne bénéficiant d'aucune prise
en charge dans le pays
c'est un culte souvent mal perçu parfois
dénigrer et qui a longtemps été
combattue par les missionnaires
chrétiens la culture vaudou est à
l'honneur à ouidah au bénin dans le
cadre de la biennale l'événement est
initiée par le laboratoire iot comptable
contemporain le vaudou suscite de plus
en plus d'intérêt surtout dans le
contexte de la question du retour des
biens culturels le bénin en veut
récupérer son leadership sur son
patrimoine identitaire qui intéresse un
nombre croissant de chercheurs et je
vous propose d'écouter la réaction de sa
majesté d'adak boy who knew nahd 2 chef
spirituel suprême du vaudou windows
la prise de conscience nous permet de
sauter de cet état de fébrilité le vos
dons n'est pas une mauvaise chose
je dois trouver les mots les mots les
expressions le comportement qu'il faut
pour que l'autre arrive à comprendre en
se débarrassant de près jugez vous avez
peut-être vu sur les réseaux sociaux les
photos de quatre joueurs du paris
saint-germain en voyage au rwanda leur
visite fait partie du partenariat noué
entre kigali et le club parisien pour
développer le football au rwanda le psg
a ouvert un centre de formation dans
pays ils sont aujourd'hui 184 jeune
talent entre 7 6 et 15 ans venus de tout
le pays pour s'entraîner avec une équipe
de coachs rwandais tous formé au psg
wohlfarth est allé à leur rencontre
abdou les passionnés de football depuis
son plus jeune âge il fait partie des
184 jeunes talents de 6 à 15 ans à avoir
intégré l'académie du paris
saint-germain rwanda après des
sélections conduit dans tout le pays da
trois entraînements par semaine je fais
des dribbles des tirs des faces
objectif de ce centre d'entraînement
repérer les meilleurs espoirs les faire
progresser et même les confronter à
d'autres équipes nous les 21 autres
joueurs vont participer à la coupe du
monde de la psg academy à paris nantes
rennes et moi ça m'aide à connaître ça
m'aide à connaître beaucoup de football
samad a continué être
136 ème du classement internationale
fifa le pays des mille collines n'est
pour le moment pas une nation du ballon
rond alors kigali a conclu un
partenariat de 10 millions d'euros par
an avec le paris saint germain pour
promouvoir son image mais aussi pour
développer son sport david fait partie
des quatre entraîneurs locaux formés par
le club parisien
d'ici cinq ans nos joueurs de l'académie
seront déjà en train de jouer pour leur
équipe nationale
dans les différents groupes d'âge
peut-être pour l'équipe de moins de 15
ans des moins de 16 ans ou de 17 ans le
partenariat vise aussi à promouvoir le
tourisme depuis 2009 le lober visite en
inde à paris au parc des princes et sur
les maillots d'entraînement du psg
sa soirée-bénéfice à socio économique ce
sont les bénéfices
provenant du tourisme des panneaux
publicitaires
de cette équipe lorsqu elle aura joué ça
va être vu par tout le monde
en 2018 le ronde a passé un accord
similaire avec arsenal le club favori du
président paul kagame un an après le
nombre de touristes venant d'europe a
augmenté de 22%
et c'est la fin du journal de l'afrique
je vous retrouve dans moins d'une heure
pour une nouvelle édition à tout à
l'heure
[Musique]
vingt ans après la fin de la guerre
l'angola n'a toujours pas tourné la page
malgré le silence des armes les
stigmates sont encore bien présents
à nos fans ont fondu en larmes en boîte
ceux qui ont lutté pour leur pays se
sentent délaissés alors que la
corruption continue amplifier les
inégalités
mais une nouvelle génération semble
prendre le relais de la contestation
avec toujours cette même idée en tête
billet retour en angola à voir sur
france 24 et france 24 points comme